brendan theo day one listener here hey
quick one
that bag lunch king interesting
gang gang buzz buzz oh dude king it bro
because you can put any snack you want
you know that nice treats waiting for
you on your break
i like to put a little fruit by the foot
maybe some [ __ ] teddy grams
and you know they're waiting for you
yeah i like maybe get that oatmeal
sandwich my fave
i like getting a little sandwich boy cut
it in half
what makes me mad is if my sandwich in
that and the lunch isn't cut in half
dude i'll lose my damn
mind bro i'll murder a [ __ ] oh i
will quit the job and hit somebody with
my truck in the afternoon [ __ ] yeah dog
i need my [ __ ] cut you cut it diagonally
go down the middle yeah
and oh i cut it you want it diagonally
yeah me too i want my i want that
i want that rectangle yeah it's nerd
alert if you cut down the middle that's
straight up nerd alert bro
i like a nice [ __ ] sandwich two
pieces of white bread you feel me this
wheat [ __ ]
white bread thick cheese thick meat
and then i like little lay's potato
chips maybe i wash it down with the
capri sun
and i got that little debbie's waiting
for me on the side now what gets sticky
with me is if you get tomatoes on there
because by the time
lunch comes around they're sweating they
sweat they sweat through
the bread and it gets yeah it gets a
little weird in there so
what you do you put them on the side dog
you put them inside their own little
package
they take them out you put them on the
sandwich that might be it
now what get me as a child you
accidentally spill your kool-aid your
thermos would spill over in your lunch
and then you got to eat the grape
you know grape grape meat sandwich yeah
that [ __ ] is tie-dye yeah [ __ ]
dripping and you gotta
you know it's actually pretty nice
though
it's disgusting i didn't mind it what's
this little thought talking about
well i actually i want to see what you
guys think of this
it's a new take on the pb j sandwich
i thought it was pretty genius
oh so every bite is different oh what's
going on there's that cream cheese honey
you got your rose jam honey marshmallow
are the rose
and then the columns are crunchy nutella
and creamy so
every bite you take is a different
combination that sounds
fantastic i wish i had that right
real quick you crunch your creamy dog
i'll go crunchy brother
i can't get any more crunchy yeah i want
them crunchier the better yeah i want to
feel them nuts in my mouth
we talk about peanut butter this whole
thing is disgusting man
damn i can't go crunchy without turning
gay i mean it's just as
every time i turn around there's just
somebody's you know
there's poops there's penises
you have a sign that says smoke my natch
yeah and i mean it
and you pointed that dude
[Laughter]
i mean it bro okay i will light up a
sweet bowl of monash dog
for any of you freaking perverts dude
speak up
chin huh [ __ ] jesus
talk about getting lunch right now you
made me super hungry
working for the irs so you started so
you started [ __ ] right now
yeah what are you eating chin yeah what
is it it's vietnamese
are you eating chocolate you eating
cheese on the job no it's food it's jack
it's vietnamese sausage meat
it stinks too bad poor nick yeah
i know right i think he only mines also
because they say for school if you bust
out snack did you bring enough for
everybody yeah
bring enough for everybody girlfriend
has been to me so he's used to that
yeah yeah i've had some for for sure
before
i had some kind of live duck or it
wasn't live but it was was it the snail
uh no it was an egg it was like a it was
like a chicken in there but it was like
fully full
of the blue egg yeah yeah yeah yeah that
shit's [ __ ] good
it was in front of her family i had to
that's disgusting that's a keeper how'd
it go
uh keeper nick it was it was all right
it honestly it just tasted like a
seasoned deviled egg but like
super heavy on the devil some poor
little chicken
let's listen to this thought sometimes
it says yes
[Music]
is